are you gonna have more kids I hope so
really hope so we Pro you know we got
like these embryos so I don't know like
but right now I you know we were gonna
like trying to make a move and Cove it
happened and I'm just kind of like like
walking exactly oh you froze your eggs
so we have a documentary that's gonna be
out on HBO max called expecting Amy and
it follows my pregnancy I had
hyperemesis which is when you have
severe nausea and vomiting through the
whole pregnancy there's no research on
it because it only happens to women
hello I mean they have trouble [ __ ]
viagra now but if your if your dick
curves slightly to the right don't worry
we've got a pill for you we don't want
you to go through that but if you are an
excruciating pain your whole life as a
woman we're so sorry we'll get to you
after we fix every slight dick problem
right but this you know one in three
babies die when the mother has it
because you can't keep any food down
like I was hospitalized like 10 times
and Wow
and it's scary because you can't nourish
the baby or yourself and it's also like
you know if you've ever had food
poisoning
it's truly that for nine and a half
months it's um
but but I all that aside because
seriously once you meet your baby you're
like oh my god I would have been sick
like that for ten years just to meet you
for an hour it was hard it was really
hard for us to get it but we got through
it
so let me understand this you had a
special a comedy special stand-up
special on Netflix that was very
successful
what you did is you filmed the behind
the scenes we see how difficult it was
to put together your stand-up special is
that but also you see you know it's like
I loved Seinfeld's movie comedian where
you follow him
developing this special so it's like I
wanted to make that and I happen to be
pregnant and sick well it's happening
but you also see the jokes like you know
evolving and it's really a lot about me
my husband and us navigating this all
this stuff together
you